me versus the peach okay I'm going to
swing the old meat mallet I'm gonna sit
on her right out of the box okay so I
could be calling for a little bit of the
old punch bagging okay buddy ready to
play the bag yeah yeah yeah give it to
me what what is it correct being in at a
TN you know it's kind of like the one
thing I didn't want to do
oh okay so what should I have left you
at parks the sink it's it's a TN man
it's the news it's Logan's
g-spot I can finger bang him all night
long I'm a direct direct to report what
sure just a TN it's it's like kind of
against my principles your principles
correct don't be an you don't
have principles dude etienne is a very
toxic element in the culture
seriously okay the name mean one
principle that you have I don't know
like I'm against racism I'm
against racism everybody's against
racism what else like don't lie
like if you're the news like you say
that's your principal yeah dude Greg
this is not Charles Dickens
world okay you don't go around talking
about principles we're all trying to do
the right thing of course we are but
come on man man the up
you